Oprah is unveiling her next highly
anticipated selection for her book club
the New York Times describes the novel
as a dissection of the American Dream
savage and compassionate in all the
right places only on CBS this morning
Oprah reveals her newest pick CBS this
morning hello everybody
all my friends at CTM I'm excited to
announce my new summer selection for
Oprah's Book Club
behold the dreamers mmm
that's it behold the dreamers and let me
tell you all this book is it is so
beautifully written and it's a debut
novel by a young woman named bolo in
play the story just takes you on a
breathless journey
it's everything our culture is grappling
with right now at least many of the
things about race and class about the
economy immigration the dangers of us
versus them mentality so when you read
it it'll feel very modern like it's
happening right now and underneath the
story pumps everything we love about a
story heart and soul of family love the
pursuit of happiness and actually what
home really means it is already been
called one of the hippest books of the
Year by The Washington Post and may I
say Washington Post I wholeheartedly
agree I think it's a great summer read
and I'm hoping that everybody gets it
before you head off for vacation next
week
it's called behold the dreamers by M
bolo in play all the dreamers is in bolo
boy's debut novel it's available in
paperback paperback brother starting
today it won the 2017 pen/faulkner award
for fiction and the Washington Post
named at one of its notable books of
2016 the author joins us now at the
table I don't want to say your name
again because I know I'm screwing it up
you say it in Balham boy Bolin wait what
congratulations to you I gradually do
this is what I know I know one of
Oprah's Favorite Things is calling the
author to let them know nothing so as a
magazine we have a very big book section
the book editor you were told that the
book editor Lee Hebert was going to call
you about a book review
so you pick up the phone and tell us
that what happened well I picked up the
phone and I hear hi in below is Oprah
and I and I was confused I said Oprah
I thought Leigh was calling me she said
yeah that's what we say babe I'm
actually calling to tell you that I
picked your book as my next book club
selection and then I totally lost it
it's so interesting it's sort of a
full-circle moment because you became a
writer because of Oprah's Book Club I
really exactly many years ago 2002 I
walked into a library in Falls Church
Virginia and Bullards Song of Solomon
and I was so in awe of that book that I
started writing and started writing as a
hobby and then when I lost my job in
marketing during the financial crisis I
got inspiration to write behold the
dreamers Wow
it's about two families living next to
each other ones or Lehman Brothers
executive and the others an immigrant
family and what happens between their
relationship yes so their family that is
the immigrant family the father gets a
job as a chauffeur for the Lehman
Brothers executive so the novel is about
how the financial crisis affected these
two very different families you know one
is a 1% money is not a problem for them
but they have other struggles in their
family and the immigrant family they
came here hoping for the American Dream
and then they find a reality that you
know it's a very tough you know
challenge achieving this American Dream
how much of your own story is in this
book well the family the book from
before my country the immigrant family
did for my hometown which is called in
become a goon and and I am an immigrant
myself and I used to live in Harlem so I
don't know the struggles of being an
immigrant in this country and you know
working really hard I'm coming here
having an idea that America was this
promised land of sorts and then finding
out that you know while it is a
wonderful country does have lots of
challenges yeah but you got the idea you
were 17 when you came and you got the
idea out of something that you saw at
Columbus Circle what did you see well I
was so sure fast waiting for executives
in front of the time when I build him
and you thought why and I thought what
is it like the relationship between
these two very different men you know
this working-class immigrant man and
this in a Wall Street executive they're
together in this car what is it
you know what what did they talk about
and how did the financial crisis affect
each of them so I became very intrigued
about the idea and I started writing
this novel what did you imagine they
talk about yeah I thought the party
talked about your families I mean the
family is very important in this novel
both families they have children and
they would hope that their children can
have a successful life and it is one of
the issues that in book deal Suites but
as the story progresses they do things
that are out of character which
surprised me mm-hmm and I thought why is
she having this these characters do
these things that seem to come that
don't seem to represent the people they
are what do you say about that
I think girl that people do things out
of curtain in real life you know I think
we don't always act the way we are I
mean maybe we have a certain character
that we live by but I think that we do
sequester ourselves and we have family
and friends who do things that make us
go I can't believe he or she did that
yeah you capture both capture you can
you capture both cultures very well the
1% and the immigrant was it a learning
curve for you to when you came here yes
yes I mean I everything I've come to a
very small town in in Cameroon and I
moved to America and it was a very
different experience and and how to
learn a lot and it's a very different
culture and I am fascinated by different
cultures America still fascinates me
after all these years yeah that's good
you is even a Donald Trump reference in
the baby from hotels really I love it
was so new your congrats to you thank
you thanks Bess all right thank you
well you can visit cBS This Morning Calm
for an excerpt of behold the dreamers
and readers guide and we'll post more
content in the coming weeks about
Oprah's Book Club
you can catch Oprah's interview you can
Bowl away and the new August issue of O
The Oprah Magazine